Female narrator: The National Library of Medicine
is proud to present Desalination.
A solution for our water needs.
[recycle logo appears]
Female narrator: [female cartoon character
speaks] Did you know that 97% of Earth's water
is saltwater from oceans?
[Cartoon boy appears.
image of Earth appears with three red arrows
pointing at water in the oceans]
Cartoon boy: Hmm!
That's a lot of water!
If there is so much ocean water, why don't
we just drink the water?
I don't get what everyone's saying about all
these water shortages and stuff.
Female: It's not that simple.
We can't drink saltwater.
Cartoon boy: Why not?
What would happen if we did drink it?
Female: Well, the salts in our food and drinks
ends up in our blood, (images of pizza, burger,
coffee, cake, and drink appear] but we can't
have too much salt in our blood.
[cross-section kidney appears]
Our kidneys use water to flush out the extra
salt, generating urine that exits the body.
This is one of the reasons we need to drink
water.
[human trunk, kidneys labeled]
Cartoon boy: But if urine leaves the body,
then getting rid of salt must cause us to
lose water from our bodies!
Female: That's correct!
And what is sea water?
Cartoon boy: I guess it's just water with
a lot of salt dissolved in it.
Female: Exactly!
So, say, you drink one cup of sea water [cup
appears], and, say, in that cup there is a
tablespoon of salt [tablespoon of salt appears].
The amount of salt in that cup of water is
so high, that it would take way more than
the one cup of liquid you drink to remove
the one tablespoon of salt from your body
[many cups appear].
Cartoon boy: So drinking sea water causes
you to lose even more water than you drink!
Female: That's right, and losing too much
water causes dehydration, which is very bad
for you.
Cartoon boy: It's such a shame, there's so
much salt water.
If we could only get rid of the salt, we wouldn't
have to worry about water shortages or anything
like that.
Female: Well, there is actually a way to remove
salt from sea water, it's called desalination,
and it's more familiar than you think.
[Flowchart of water cycle appears: precipitation,
evaporation, transpiration, condensation.]
Female: During the water cycle, water gets
desalinated.
After rainfall the water flows toward the
ocean.
Energy from the sun causes the salty water
to evaporate, leaving the minerals on the
ground.
The pure water travels upward as a gas until
it hits cold air and condenses, forming clouds.
Then fresh water falls as rain.
Cartoon boy: Hold on, condenses?
What's that?
Female: What is condensing?
It's when water gas cools and turns into a
liquid.
Have you ever drawn pictures on the bathroom
mirror after you took a shower?
The water on the mirror came from your shower.
When the water is hot, part of it turns into
gas, which then rises in the air.
When the gas comes into contact with a cold
mirror, it cools, or condenses, and turns
into water.
Again, clouds are just condensed water in
the air, and those clouds produce rain.
Although nature produces fresh water, it is
a precious but limited resource.
Desalinating ocean water provides much needed
freshwater for people to drink, especially
those in locations without much.
Cartoon boy: So how do they do it?
Female: Well, there are two types of desalination.
The first is called thermal desalination.
[Illustration of thermal desalination appears.]
Thermal desalination is similar to the water
cycle.
Saltwater is heated so that it evaporates,
leaving the salt behind.
The evaporated steam is then cooled and condensed
into pure water.
Cartoon boy: Like on the bathroom mirror!
Female: Thermal desalination is a good method
because it works, and can handle large volumes
[picture of water silo].
However, it does use up a lot of energy [picture
of lightning].
Another method of desalination is membrane
desalination, which uses semi-permeable membranes.
A semi-permeable membrane is a thin sheet
of material with tiny holes that let some
amount of liquids, such as water, but not
solids like salt, to pass through it.
To desalinate, membranes are used in a process
called reverse osmosis.
This process involves tanks divided by a membrane.
Pressure is applied to the saltwater side,
forcing water through the membrane from the
side where there is more salt, to where there
is no salt.
Since the membrane only lets liquids in, the
salt gets left behind.
Reverse osmosis is more efficient than thermal
desalination, meaning it produces more freshwater
for less money.
However, a reason not to use reverse osmosis
is that salt and other particles get stuck
in the membrane holes, causing them to stop
working.
Membranes also get old and break down.
Because of their short lifespan, membranes
must be replaced frequently, which is expensive.
Cartoon boy: That makes sense.
So if we have these technologies, why are
there still water shortages?
Female: Industrial desalination is not yet
our main source of drinking water because
it requires a lot of energy, making it expensive
and harmful to the environment.
Furthermore, harmful leftover salt is hard
to dispose of safely.
However, scientists have started combining
technologies to make desalination more efficient,
such as using both membrane and thermal desalination
technologies together and finding better ways
to power desalination plants.
Cartoon boy: So while we have a long way to
go, desalination really is a solution for
our water needs.
The End.